the jurogan experience but anyway uh but
yeah no the the the thing with biden
talking about um
you know how white supremacy is the
biggest threat
it's clearly
there's clearly something deeply wrong
with this country that there clearly is
domestic white terrorism there's no
question that that it exists but they've
become
really really loose with that term like
the written house case was a classic
example for for me right of
of how you just you have to be more
careful about like they were calling
them a white supremacist or something
the person that called them a white
supremacist the president called them
like just just in the level of libel
yeah we used to be afraid to do that
right like you would have to have
something that allowed you to say
that this guy was a white supremacist
before you put that on the air in print
because you'd be afraid of being sued
you'd be the end of your career yeah um
and all they really had were some vague
cultural markers right like would i tell
my kid to pick up an ar-15 and go go to
a protest absolutely not but
you know as a journalist i can't call
him that
unless i have something more there was a
the difference between calling it a
protest and the air of fear and chaos
that was prevalent
when
that whole thing went down this was post
the george floyd riots and everything
was crazy in los angeles they were
lighting cop cars on fire there were
pallets of bricks that are mysteriously
dropped off at protest sites and windows
were smashed through beverly hills they
had an early curfew people have quick
memories
they have short memories and they forget
how [ __ ] crazy it was like right
after that george floyd protest or right
after george floyd's murder when
everybody was
chaotic like the the country was in a
state of chaos
that's when that happened right so this
kid was asked by i think they had a used
car lot by the way have you ever seen
the guys who uh he was
told they're indian
i think they're indian
i think
i think if this is accurate i got
another meme for you because i love
memes
oh i'll find it um
i mean the other thing about that case
was that
you know the the
the protests in kenosha were about the
jacob blake case which was yes and you
know i wrote a book about the eric
garner case uh which was
you know
unequivocally
a brutal police killing where the police
were at fault like no question about it
but the
the blake incident was much more
complicated right right and there's a
reason like if you look at the reasons
why
the the d.a
and
uh
and the civil rights division of the
justice department
didn't file charges in that case is
because there was a lot of stuff about
that case that was
you know
made it made it there's a lot of gray
area in terms of the decision making
that the that the police made there and
people naturally assumed this is this is
what we do know we see something on on
twitter we see like a 20-second piece of
video we think we know the whole story
but the rea the reality is most of the
time the initial impression of news is
wrong uh at least somewhere there's
usually some kind of error built in and
that's why we need the next two and
three days and months to sort out
exactly what happened but
and in that case you know we we just
didn't um
it
there there were a lot of ambiguities
that just got turned instantaneously
into into a narrative that um
you know that was really unfortunate
there's also a frantic rush and
to say that someone was racist or a
white supremacist and there was a
narrative that that was rewarded
paul this meme that i just sent you this
is why i sent it
i have a whole meme folder on my iphone
that i just can't wait to use
so he wanted to protect a business owned
by these guys
i don't know if they're middle eastern
or
indian or what what they were
it says shoots these guys and shows
shoots three white guys
right worst white supremacist ever not
only that but one of the guys that he
shot was
a repeat offender
child rapist
right the guy in the middle i mean he he
raped multiple children mentally ill i
mean yeah literally one of the
it's just one of the worst crimes you
could imagine
but they
sort of without hesitation people would
do things like
say
well it's clearly a problem that they're
um
you know there weren't enough
uh minorities in the jury
in this case where they're everybody
involved was white
um i think a lot of
a lot of the news consumers were sort of
led to believe certain things
just by the way
by implication they were
they they didn't always identify whether
the people who got shot were white or
black or anything they would just sort
of say they were shot
meanwhile they would say repeatedly that
what that written house was white i have
friends that are black that didn't know
that they were white victims until the
trial started right and that said dude i
thought he shot black people
they didn't they literally didn't know
and so the thing was it was a black
lives matter protest
he shot people they thought he shot
black people they thought he was a
racist and then the president calls him
a white supremacist i got the picture
right right and and you can see how that
can happen yes if you if you're just
picking up you know the newspaper or
you're watching cnn and they're just
neglecting to leave out certain details
um which you know it has to be strategic
and again this is this this gets back to
what i was saying before it's not like
anybody tells you to do this right you
just sort of know that
the story is gonna sell better or it's
going to play better
if you highlight certain things right
and and i think that's what happens with
you know with a lot of the people in
this case and i i
it's it's uncomfortable to talk about
this stuff because people assume that
you have sympathies with somebody like
rittenhouse or you know all the people
who
lionized them on you know on fox fox
news that's not it you just you just got
to get the stuff right
you have a heightened responsibility to
get it right when people are amped up
and they're and they're mad and they're
ready to go out in the streets and fight
each other yeah that's when you have to
be super careful about what you say you
know especially in media